un désert de cailloux des croix en bois
avec des noms et des dates des tombes
entouré de pierre
l'aménagement est simple mais ses
habitants n'ont pas le choix les semis
tiers de lima ne peuvent pas accueillir
tous les corps des victimes du coc vide
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de place mais
aussi parce que l'entrée est trop cher
car il faut payer pour avoir une
sépulture à cause du coronavirus si les
nanterre les gens d'en haut qu'un
cimetière autour de kalaba lots ils ne
peuvent les enterrer qu'ici parce que
des gens d'autres endroits viennent ici
ils viennent de come as de vitalité car
aucun cimetière ne les reçoit le seul
qui puisse les recevoir si un cimetière
pour lequel il faut payer et si vous
n'avez pas d'argent que fait de ce
cimetière improvisé a été créée par les
proches des victimes les plus pauvres du
coronavirus dans le district de qarabagh
îlot dans la provence de lima la
capitale selon le ministère de la santé
plus de 26000 personnes sont mortes du
virus au pérou depuis le début de
l'épidémie
ces familles désemparées dénonce aussi
la prise en charge des soins
inégalitaire pour les patients atteints
du coc vide
mes deux fils sont arrivés à cayetano
heredia
c'est là qu'ils sont morts ils m'ont dit
qu'il n'y avait pas de lits de soins
intensifs
ceux ci sont pour les gens qui ont de
l'argent il n'y a pas de salut pour les
pauvres
il n'y en a pas le pérou compte près de
540 mille cas confirmés de coronavirus
et l'épidémie continue de progresser
dimanche les autorités ont enregistré
dix mille nouveaux cas en 24 heures un
record